[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle saison culturelle sur
tv 78 rendez vous que vous pouvez
dorénavant suivre le mardi et on
commence tout de suite le sommaire du
mardi 11 septembre deux jours pour
visiter les yvelines à travers le
patrimoine le thème de cette année l'art
du partage nous ferons le tour des
différents rendez vous à ne pas manquer
sur son compte en libye et rambouillet
la commander des templiers devient la
commanderie l'agglomération souhaite en
faire un lieu multiculturel où se
rencontreront danseurs musiciens
artistes ou encore pour 70 à guyancourt
on voyage jusqu'à chicago avec les peaux
tahoua tony un peuple nord amérindiens
ces derniers ont inspiré isabelle
olivier artiste en résidence à la ferme
de bénévoles pour leur 35e édition des
journées européennes du patrimoine vont
mettre en avant l'art du partage 50 pays
européens vont ils participer 17 milieu
ouvert 26000 animations et certaines
d'entre elles ont bien sûr lieu près de
chez vous pour en parler art mais
l'ouvrier la vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge de
la culture et mathilde baraillé chargé
des actions éducatives et culturelles de
rambouillet où jouera toutes les deux un
genre dont il ajoute on devait revoir
mais l'embryon va commencer à saint
quentin en yvelines lors du partage se
décline notamment dans les lieux majeurs
du territoire
oui comme au niveau du patrimoine
en fait on a repris tout ce qui est
important sur rosa au niveau de la
réguler et du patrimoine
donc ça va aussi bien des églises avec
que la ferme du mas nec
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore le théâtre de
50 ans
le côté architectural et c'est un
premier c'est un premier thème
après on a un deuxième thème qui
correspond à l'évolution de la vie et on
a aussi les jardins et on a différentes
manières de visites et de visiter tout
ça alors à rambouillet là par contre ma
matière de barrages et on part pour un
tour d'europe avec des visites
découvertes
oui tout à fait cette année on propose
donc deux visites découvertes une donc
dans le centre ville de rambouillet où
il va s'agir donc de découvrir un petit
peu ces différentes architectures
remarquable donc inspiré donc par dix
fait différent en fait pays européens
donc on va avoir l'inspiration des
temples grecs des palais florentin et
une autre visite donc plus une balade en
fait dans le parc de rambouillet à la
découverte des jardins encore une fois
dans inspiration européenne alors à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aussi l'europe
elle est pas oubliée puisque sont comme
les journées européennes du patrimoine
il ya des balades urbaines proposer
notamment des visites flash c'est le
nouveau régime
oui ça c'est la nouveauté c'est à dire
différents sites avec une interprète
enfin une explication accompagné de qui
dure environ 25 minutes mais pour des
personnes qui veulent énormément de deux
visites flash est en fait il est aussi
possible de pas de participer en quarts
à ces visites flash et de se déplacer de
deux points un point sur tous les
territoires des 12 milles et c'est
surtout en plus des lieux insolites
il y a le tunnel qui passe au dessus de
la gare il ya alors il ya par exemple la
perspective marta pan mais il ya aussi
le quartier de villas quoi il y apprend
la cité des dents de scie il ya la ferme
du manège voyez ces traits mais en fait
ça représente bien aussi l'évolution de
50 ha ça permet de se découvrir tous ces
petits lieux que en grenat en trois ans
qu'on ne voit plus quand ils
l'architecturé c'est tellement intégré
on ne se rend plus compte que je sais
qu'à un patrimoine est justement à
rambouillet aussi c'était la volonté de
mettre en avant ses petits yeux qu'on
l'on passe tous les jours et on
plus attention oui donc on a des visites
commentées donc de certains monuments
pourtant remarquable à rambouillet donc
on va notamment pouvoir avoir le
dimanche des visites de l'église saint
lubin
donc voilà église du 19e construite par
l'architecte anatole de baudot qui était
un des élèves de viollet-le-duc on a
également donc les portes ouvertes ont
encore une fois dont de l'hôtel de ville
qui vont permettre de découvrir la salle
du conseil donc où sont abrités des
collections puisqu'on va pouvoir
découvrir donc des des portraits de
personnages historiques de rambouillet
et également la célèbre une célèbre
carte des chasses qui a été commandé par
louis 15 est également donc visitable le
cabinet du maire donc ce qui plaît
beaucoup en général souvent dans les
journées européennes du patrimoine c'est
de pouvoir découvrir des lieux qui sont
fermés au public et c'est le cas à 50
ans on va pouvoir découvrir l'envers du
décor des coulisses aux délais un homme
de théâtre de 54-51 on va pouvoir
visiter les réserves de
et donc en partie fait tout ce qui est
design du musée de la police
on va pouvoir voir les cabines de
projection du cinéma ugc est oui alors
justement l'ugc vous en parler on va
écouter marc allemand grave s et son
directeur et il nous donne des
précisions sur ce qui va se passer ce
week-end on va découvrir un petit peu ce
que la vie d'une cabine nous on appelle
ça une cabine des projectionnistes
on va pouvoir découvrir un petit peu
leur métier les machines sur lesquelles
il travaille et l'évolution qui a eu
depuis peu de temps pour que voilà ils
ont une autre vision quand ils viennent
au cinéma qui disent il ya des gens qui
travaillent derrière il ya tout un
processus tout une technique qui permet
une diffusion d'un film alors toutes les
visites proposées se font sur
inscription auprès du musée de la vie
donc on avant la du théâtre on avoir des
musées on a parlé du g7 il ya aussi des
des animations peu particulière à
l'espace que je de plaisir c'est une
troupe qui va montrer comment se crée
une pièce c'est vraiment l'idée ça de
montrer tout ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses de l'agglomération au bruit
dans tout ce que l'on peut faire et on
fait des choses qu'on peut pas mourir
tout le temps que c'est le moment au
moment des journées du patrimoine
et effectivement c'est un programme
qu'on fait varier chaque chaque année en
s'adaptant si possible au terme métier
de pareils et c'est aussi on a parlé d'
hôtel de ville du cabinet du maire ce
n'est pas nécessairement l'endroit où le
public rentre le plus facilement
comment on prépare des journées du
patrimoine comme ça ce que chaque année
on cherche une petite particularité à
mettre en avant
on se respecte le thème on se dire les
chenilles à cette petite chose qu'on n'a
jamais montré
alors oui c'est sûr qu'on essaie
toujours de mettre deux pros de proposer
de nouvelles visites ou là par exemple
au palais du roi de rome en propose
beaucoup d'animation puisque en effet le
samedi
il va y avoir un concert donc un goût
d'un groupe rambolitains qui s'appelle
ozenne donc de rock progressif qui qui
vient en fait alimenté la fin d'une
exposition temporaire puisque vous allez
voir venir découvrir les tous derniers
jours de notre exposition temporaire qui
s'appelle donc de rouille et d'acier de
l'artiste bertrand père au noir en vol
et un tout à fait et en plus donc
rambolitains puissance est un artiste
qui a un travail assez intéressant
puisqu'il il mène un travail en fait et
d'expérimentation sur la matière en
exposant des plaques de métal à la
dégradation et à la corrosion
voilà donc une réflexion aussi sur le
temps qui passe donc voilà donc au
palais de la drogue va se passer donc
dont beaucoup de choses et surtout
l'artiste est présent
en fait j'ai tardé à changer de voile à
jour bertrand verreault sera présent sur
les deux jours pour échanger avec le
public sur son travail mais pas l'idiot
rade roms c'est pas seulement
l'exposition le site en lui-même a une
histoire titre qui mise en avant de ces
journées j'imagine tout à fait puisque
des visites commentées également de l'
architecture du palais mais aussi de son
petit jardin puisque donc on a le palais
on a le petit jardin qui seront
également donc commentées par nos guides
conférenciers également dans l'atelier
du patrimoine
un atelier d'écriture donc sera sera mis
en place
donc par petits groupes donc une heure
d'atelier
on va pouvoir justement discuter
dialoguer sur qu'est ce que le
patrimoine qu'est ce que le représentent
le patrimoine pour chacun d'entre nous
et à la fin de cet atelier le but étant
de réaliser donc un poème poèmes dont
qui pourra participer pour les personnes
pourront peut-être souhaité de
participer au concours patrimoine en
poésie qui a été lancé par la région ile
de france
c'est ça c'est la nouveauté pour vous à
rambouillet cette année la poésie met en
avant c'est à dire que les monuments ne
sont plus là tout seul on les met en
lumière tout à fait et puis on
s'interroge aujourd'hui aussi sur qu'est
ce que le patrimoine qu'est ce que sont
ces monuments pour les rambolitains pour
nous qu'est ce que ça représente voit
sur toutes ces réflexions sur la notion
de conservation de restauration du
patrimoine pour quoi pour qui passait
des choses qu'on essaie de mettre en
avant les fêtes
des animations il y en a aussi à 50 ans
et pas seulement des visites justes
noces est passé ces visites il ya des
animations il y aura des animations à la
commanderie des templiers et a en plus
des liens avec le sport donc on aura des
visites à vélo on aura des moments du
rapport avec la bibliothèque
universitaire on va aller visiter aussi
le château de plaisir où là il ya aussi
des petites représentations des choses
comme ça il ya un programme un programme
mais en même temps on parle de justement
de l'europe sur effectivement on a
énormément d'artistes européens aussi
qu'ils ont et des oeuvres d'art sur sur
la ville où ont participé à la
conscription sur sur saint quentin et
puis au niveau 2 1 on à la ryder cup
c'est quand même le rhum ou le soir et
donc en fait en plus une exposition
temporaire sur l'évolution du sport et
l'implication maintenant du sport dans
la vie de tous les jours
au musée de l'api dont un sujet sera à
découvrir sur notre antenne dans le 7-8
loisirs de ce jeudi
alors on a parlé du palais du rhin
grande rambouillet mais il est aussi
dans le jardin du palais du rhin rome
une petite maison qui attire notre
attention là on pourra pas rentrer
dedans ces pavillons du verger parce qu'
il est très dégradé mais il a une
histoire
oui donc on a en effet un petit pavillon
dans ce jardin bio rad robe non qui date
du xviiie siècle et à l'intérieur donc
il ya des décors assez exceptionnel
alors on ne pourra pas rentrer à
l'intérieur tout simplement voilà comme
on dit qui est assez dégradés et il est
actuellement donc en cours de rénovation
voilà donc ils rentrent dans un projet
de rénovation donc on va présenter ce
projet et on pourra quand même admirer
exceptionnellement par la fenêtre
entrouverte l'intérieur pour découvrir
les dix avions dont un outil mais avant
tout à fait toute sa particularité
alors le thème c'est l'heure du partage
déjà plusieurs reprises et ça se voit
notamment dans les programmations ce
qu'il ya des villes qui ont décidé de
s'associer cette année pour proposer un
programme complet et c'est le cas de
manque pas et l'encours et coignières
laurent mazaury le maire adjoint en
charge de la culture de la commune d'el
en cours nous en explique les raisons
cette association tombait sous le sens
parce qu'il ya une vraie vie locale
commune à la fois aujourd'hui maintenant
tout de suite mais également dans le
passé l'ensemble de ces trois communes
appartenait d'un point de vue religieux
puisque bien entendu l'histoire de la
france est aussi l'histoire la religion
catholique
en tout cas à l'époque au diocèse de
noyon etc ces trois communes avaient la
part crise d'avoir à la fois une
commanderie lac henry étant plié mais
également des églises directement sous
la responsabilité de deux diocèses de
noyon et lors de ce week-end vous
pourrez notamment visiter l'église
saint-médard d'elancourt le samedi ou
encore assister à un concert autour des
fables de la fontaine à coignières le
signer cette nuit vous accueille pour
une conférence sur les templiers précédé
d'une projection d'un film au thème tout
trouvé
les templiers regardez je suis p mène de
blaye broc en vrille et au nom est
devenu des gens
as tu dois amener la sorcière à séverac
où tu détruira ses pouvoirs c'est elle
la sorcière
ce n'est pas ce que je vois j'emmènerai
la fille si elle n'est pas celle que
vous dites
vous ne voudrez pas
ce n'est pas comme les autres
tu crois que je suis une sorcière de
même
vous faites pas abuser elle voit les
faiblesses qui entravent locale ils sont
servis raconte rhône euros alors
j'imagine que pour beaucoup de vos
rendez vous il faut notamment s'inscrire
est ce qu'il reste des places à
rambouillet notamment alors nous ce
n'est pas sur inscription donc tout le
monde peut venir de partout même les
petits échanges alors il y a donc
l'atelier du patrimoine atelier
d'écriture dont je parlais donc on
accepte environ douze personnes un
groupe de 12 personnes
voilà en sachant que sous les 2 jours on
propose six sessions six sessions d'une
heure qu'on se laisse ça laisse un peu
de temps alors parfois dans cinquante
ans la il ya beaucoup de il ya pas mal
d'inscriptions à respecter on passera
après nous et tout est expliqué sur le
site de saint quentin et puis il ya une
petite brochure les organise les
journées du patrimoine qui explique bien
ce qui se passe le samedi ce qui se
passe le dimanche ce qui se passe les
les deux jours voilà parce qu'il faut
faire la part des choses entre chaque
rendez vous très bien il n'y a pas que
saint quentin en yvelines ya pas que
rambouillet il y aussi de nombreux
autres sites qui ouvrent leurs portes
alors il y à l'inria art concours avec
une exposition sur l'histoire de
l'informatique
il y à la préfecture et l'hôtel du
département l'a7 à versailles eux ils
ouvrent leur salon il ya aussi le
domaine de madame elisabeth toujours à
versailles mais aussi le château qui
propose cette année une ouverture
exceptionnelle celle du grand commun qui
est aujourd'hui le siège des services
administratifs il a été construit sous
le dit la direction de jules hardouin
mansart qui est l architecte du roi
merci à toutes les deux d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation alors les rendez vous
sont à retrouver sur les sites internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran que ce
point ce qu'il point fr pour
saint-quentin de vienne en juillet point
fr pour embrouiller armelle haut brion
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
parler d'une autre actualité
saint-quentinoise mais avant pour
conclure notre page journées du
patrimoine un mot sur le loto du
patrimoine alors 2 169 sites vont
bénéficier de ce loto il a été lancé le
3 septembre dernier par stéphane bern
deux d'entre deux décident pardon senti
vinoy il ya le château 10 où est la
villa viardot à bougival
c'est ce qu'on voit à l'image de the
pursuit soutenir le patrimoine le jeu de
g
ge et le super loto dont le tirage aura
lieu le vendredi 14 septembre
un autre sujet mais on reste à 50 ans
cette fois pour sa première exposition
temporaire de l'année le musée de la
ville délocalisent le design investi la
commanderie à elancourt une quarantaine
de pièces issues des collections du
musée est exposé dans la chapelle une
plongée au coeur des années 60 70 soit
gardée non ce ne sont pas des
médicaments
ces gélules sont des lampes pilot là
toute droite sortie de l'imagination de
césarée casati et manu et les ponts diot
bienvenue dans les années 60 70 avec une
expo nommé design après garde le
mobilier l'électroménager se caractérise
par une forme de fonctionnalités de
rationalité et à partir des années 60 il
est remise en cause de ce rationalisme
et là le le design oriente des voies
nouvelles
beaucoup plus pop et joyeuse dans son
expression plastique esthétique avec des
formes très coloré
des formes originales qui remettent un
petit peu en question les moeurs du
siège de jardin of de peter guide 6 à la
lampe de table d'ettore sottsass une
quarantaine d'oeuvres et rassembler
choisi parmi les 3000 pièces de la
collection design et mode de vie du
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
un choix européen on a les italiens les
français qui sont en attendant très bien
représentés dans nos collections et qui
sont deux ter très très active du design
après hier et dans les années 60 sont
dit on encore au delà on a un îlot au
centre qui est consacré designer
scandinave
puis les anglais et les
et les allemands les années 60 sont dix
sont ouvre la voie à ce qu'on appelle
après le postmodernisme comme son
l'indiqué période qui fait suite au
modernisme et qui revendique à la fois
des notions historiques à des rôles et
décoratives dans le dans le mobilier un
retour 50 ans en arrière avec parfois
l'impression de pénétrer dans la maison
de l'oncle de jacques tati armelle aubry
y est je le rappelle vous êtes la vice
présidente en charge de la culture sur
saint quentin en yvelines
cette exposition s'intègre au fait dans
une nouvelle vie pour la commanderie
oui au niveau de la commande et on va
regarder les arts visuels qu'on avait
qu'on avait déjà l'atelier des sciences
et tout ce qui tourne autour des
sciences
et puis il y à une partie dans ce qui va
arriver
millar à la commanderie donc il y aura
des spectacles de danse mais qui seront
répartis sur les huiles du territoire et
en plus on pourra y faire des
démonstrations de lens ou des ateliers
de danse alors on est plutôt dans la
danse hip hop que sa propre adaptation
du classique et tout mais plutôt dans la
danse urbaine mais avec deux dans tous
les cas c'est pour développer et montrer
l'art de vivre à saint quentin
l'image de 50 en terre terre
d'innovation même temps on veut en faire
un lieu de vie ouvert donc en même temps
il y aura un café éphémère et on pourra
profiter de tout l'espace de classe
ouvrira lorsqu'il y aura des événements
qui les g événement programmé alors on
faire imaginer par exemple l'hiver
effectivement ça sera plus plus rare que
l'été on devrait avoir une ouverture
beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus important l'idée c'est
d'en faire un pôle multiculturel ce que
vous avez parlé de la danse mais aussi
de la poésie ce que les itinéraires
poétique venir s'installer de la musique
qui peut y avoir de la musique mais ce
sera essentiellement la danse le les
arts visuels et la et l'atelier des
sciences parce que ça aussi une idée de
promouvoir le territoire de saint
quentin et d'aller avec les thèmes de de
saint quentin et c'est comme pour le
musée de la ville ça montre l'art de
vivre sur saint quentin et comment on
peut évoluer au niveau culturel comme on
évolue au niveau des nouvelles
technologies tout et surtout la
particularité de ce territoire
mais pourquoi vous avez choisi ce site
là il souffrait peut-être d'un certain
anonymat quand c'était l'atelier des
sciences 1 parce que c'était un site qui
est resté intercommunale parce qu'en
fait le plus gros des compétences
culturelles sur comme un rester dans
l'est dans les villes donc c'était un
site intercommunal et effectivement il
faut qu'on y amène du il faut qu on y
amène du monde et on s'est aperçu que
quand on faisait les ateliers d'art
qu'on faisait l'art visuel et qu'on
faisait les râteliers et sciences d'un
en étant d'un bon niveau et en montrant
justement ce qui était saint quentin en
yvelines on attirer du monde c'est ça
que l'on est en fait on a la même chose
on a eu des tas de réussite dans le
domaine de la danse urbaine
arthur et moi c'est ce qui attire parce
que jean michel fourgous que j'ai
rencontrés samedi lors de l'inauguration
parler aussi axé sur les jeunes
oui on m'y intéresser les jeunes alors
ça peut être les très jeunes le scolaire
mais je suis large les jeunes très large
mais pour moi en fait c'est viser tout
le monde parce que si vous voulez
j'entendais des commentaires qui
disaient à partir de 40 ans les noms
c'est c'est c'est l'apanage et il faut
qu'on trouve justement des activités qui
permettent aux familles de venir mais
aux personnes qui n'ont plus d'enfants
en bas âge et dont les enfants peuvent
se débrouiller tout seul aussi de
s'intéresser
c'est aussi à travers tout ça montre et
le territoire de saint quentin et l'art
de vivre à sa campagne est de faire se
rencontrer plusieurs partenaires tout
est fait notamment les associations les
itinéraires politiques ont assisté oui
mais en même temps d'amener sur le
territoire des gens extérieurs au
territoire aussi bien en tant que
spectateurs qu'en tant qu'artiste mais
qui correspondent à ce que l'on fait sur
50 ha ça veut dire est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer des résidences d'artistes qui
voudraient bien martin l'eliana
deschamps déjà aussi bien au niveau
individuel qu'au niveau de la danse y en
a déjà
alors justement pour sa première saison
la programmation et l trimestriels ça
permet aussi de faire découvrir ça
permet surtout da comment d'avancé parce
que si vous voulez quand vous vous
installer de nouvelles activités dans un
nouveau lieu il faut aussi voir comment
on peut adapter ses nouvelles activités
au lieu donc on avance étape par étape
et justement la première étape sera
l'heure les journées du patrimoine nous
tourner par les coûts talent un autre
les journées du les journées de batman
ou paix en fait cette première étape
s'est effectivement l'exposition que
vous venez de montres et de design à la
commanderie des templiers est en fait
justement sur cette évolution est au
niveau du musée de la ville on a de tels
collection est de telle collection que
c'est bien de pouvoir avoir un espace
qui montre comment on évolue tout ce que
nous réserve 50 ans et plus à la merci
armelle ouvriers d'être venu on peut
naturellement pour tout connaître des
évènements à la commanderie direction le
site internet
un peu de musique à présent isabelle
olivier découvert les peaux tahoua tommy
lors d'un séjour aux états unis prise de
passion pour ce peuple noir amérindiens
elle s'en inspire dans son nouvel album
in between elle en propose quelques
extraits le week-end dernier lors du
forum des associations de guyancourt
c'est aucun un typique isabelle olivier
vous emmène en voyage
la musicienne par le dépôt tahoua tommy
des indiens du michigan qui habitait
chicago avant que la ville ne se crée je
me suis installé il ya six ans là bas et
en regardant le lac et la rivière et en
me disant l'histoire de chicago j'ai
trouvé vraiment si indien ottawa tommy
passionnant et du coup je suis parti à
leur recherche j'ai eu composé un
morceau pour eux qui s'appelle potable
et aux mines
[Musique]
je pense que on a oublié un peu que
l'histoire des états unis s'est
construite grâce à ces indiens et que
l'histoire de chicago s'est construite
grâce à un haïtien quelques morceaux à
la harpe pour entrer au coeur du peuple
rassemblé dans le neuvième album de
l'artiste in between lé déclinera dans
une création les 16 et 17 octobre
prochains avec le danseur et chorégraphe
ifrad ya j'ai pensé justement comme
étant un entre deux entre évidemment les
etats-unis la france où j'habite à des
deux côtés de l'atlantique mais aussi
comme un autre civilisation en train
entre cultures en train entre âge on est
finalement tous désignent between entre
deux pays entre des cultures entre deux
âges je crois que chaque discipline va
s'enrichir de ce fait de rencontres donc
l'art peut-être un peu trop conne était
dans le chapitre romantique et moi je me
suis fait connaître plutôt dans le jazz
et les musiques improvisées décloisonner
les styles pour faire découvrir le monde
isabelle olivier débute une résidence
culturel de deux ans à la ferme de bel
ébat de guyancourt
[Rires]
[Musique]
le centre alfred de vigny lance sa
saison avec une exposition celle de
laetitia gi charest les photographies ni
monteyne et ses clichés sont à découvrir
à partir du 13 septembre
pour les passionnés de harry potter ce
rendez vous et pour vous le cinéma ugc
skywest propose un marathon ce week-end
encore longtemps les huit films premier
coup de baguette samedi 15 septembre à
10 heures sous verre puis sa sorcière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi
on vous a raconté qu'un certain mage
noir est de nouveau parmi nous arrive
sans toi le hasard décidera du sort de
notre monde
pas le choix
il ne doit pas les jouer
vous n'avez pas là moi
vous resterez avec moi tout seul jusqu'à
la fin
aversenq c'est un seul en scène qui vous
attend celui de fanny ardant
la comédienne interprète hiroshima mon
amour bertrand marcos adapté le scénario
écrit par la célèbre marguerite duras
pour allart est né pour le film de 1959
et on regarde justement l'extrait la
nuit ça ne s'arrête jamais à hiroshima
j'aimerais ça s'arrête at il aussi
[Musique]
je me souviens l'avoir entendu avant
l'avant pendant que nous aimions c'est
la fin de ce site une culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain
[Musique]